I love e3 I've been making games for  about 26 years over 12 here at Xbox so  I've been to a lot of shows basically  every show they let me go to since early  1989 I like to spend much of my time as  possible helping teams make their games  great last year we announced Killer  Instinct one of the games I worked on in  my past I was thrilled with the response  to the show of course it launched and  I'm looking forward to paying people  this week with TJ combo the idea of  rebooting old beloved old games is  something that I have a lot of passion  for so we're doing it again there's  another game that I've always wanted to  bring back from the original Xbox some  would call it a cult classic but I think  honestly design great design is what we  should be looking for when we're  deciding what games we should build so  I'm honored to be up here on the stage  today to announce well let's just watch  the trailer  you